herzlich willkommen zur küchefrei das
neue Format bei dem ich meine Gäste dazu
anhalte ihr Lieblingsgericht
mitzubringen nice welches Gericht es ist
erfahre ich erst vor Ort mein Gast darf
sich in meiner Küche breit machen und
zusammen wagen wir uns an die
Zubereitung mein erster Gast ist niemand
geringeres als Johannes B Kerner
herzlich willkommen zur Küche
[Musik]
frei
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sally Welt
ich habe heute einen ganz besonderen
Gast da ich muss auch zugeben ich bin
ein bisschen aufgeregt weil es für mich
natürlich schon immer so ist ich meine
ich moderiere hier die Sendung immer
durch aber ich bin halt keine
Moderatorin eigentlich und jetzt habe
ich wirklich einen waschechten ganz
professionellen Moderator bei mir der
kein Koch ist der kein Koch ist aber der
auch ein begnadeter Koch ist muss ich
schon sagen denn er hatte ja auch schon
seine eigene Kochsendung eine sehr
erfolgreiche und Kochbücher hat er auch
schon geschrieben Johannes B kerner ist
heute zu Gast danke für die Einladung
gerne wä mein Papa jetzt da WD würden
ihm jetzt die Tränen schon den Augen
stehen weil er dann immer so aufgeregt
ist und so stolz dass er sagt mein Gott
wer kommt denn alles zu dir nach Hause
wie süß lie grüß ma ich auf jeden Fall
wer weiß vielleicht kommt das später
einfach vorbei und ist einfach
mittendrin wir haben uns beide nicht
wirklich vorbereitet wir haben uns
könnte lustig werden
könteustig werden vor kurzem
kennengelernt ja richtig ich weiß nicht
ob du dich noch dran erinnerst ich hatte
Dich glaube ich vor einem halben Jahr
mal im Hotel getroffen und kurz
angesprochen und jetzt war ich ja vor
kurzem bei dir zu Gast bei ter und das
war sehr schön war richtig schön und ich
habe mir gedacht ich bin jetzt mal so
mutig und frei und frag ob du kommst
hast aber nicht damit gerechnet dass ich
eine Woche später hier stehe ne jetzt
hast du den Salat deswegen ich bin
richtig glücklich schön dass du da bist
vielen Dank für die Einladung ich freue
mich auch das ist ja wirklich eine eine
Welt ja das ist eine Welt hier das ist
sellies also ich bin ganz beeindruckt ja
also wirklich richtig cool danke dass du
da bist und wir haben ein bisschen was
eingekauft denn wir machen ja
heute wir machen heute deine
Leibspeise zum das eine ist meine
lespeise und an dem anderen versuche ich
mich immer genau also es gab
verschiedene Challenges zum einen wusste
ich nicht was Graubrot ist ich muss
googeln ganz einfach zwischen Weißbrot
und Schwarzbrot ist
graubrotchbrot haben wir jetzt besorgt
und ich habe deine Lieblingstorte
gebacken ich hatte ein Rezept ich hatte
kein Foto und habe mir gedacht ich
mach's jetzt einfach darf ich was sagen
schon also du hast die Luxusvariante
gemacht die habe ich in meinem ganzen
Leben so nicht gegessen ist mein
Geburtstagskuchen den meine Mama früher
mich Gemach für mich gemacht hat ein
ganz einfacher aber sehr leckerer Kuchen
ich habe vorher gesagt wenn dem keiner
schmeckt ist ganz egal ich esse ihn auch
alleine also noch sieht so aus WoW und
WoW ja wer Hal sehen ne ob es so
funktioniert hat am liebsten wür
ich so schmeckt wie bei der sicher
sicher sicher sicher sicher ich finde es
ist schon immer eine harte Challenge
wenn man sagt hier das ist mein
Lieblingskuchen von Mama von Oma weil ja
es ist ja für mich hängen ganz viele
Erinnerungen dran we man da eigentlich
nicht rankommt als externer Mensch weil
da viel Liebe von Mama drin warten wir
mal warten wir mal was geht ja gut
ehrlich dich judchen deswegen lassen wir
das mal bis zum Schluss ne habe ich
jetzt gedacht okay was gibt heute
Fischstäbchen ich habe gedacht
Fischstäbchen geht immer aus dem teker
nicht aus dem teker nee beinah aber aber
so ein bisschen in der Art ja weil was
ist Fischstäbchen eigentlich ja jetzt
kein hochwertiger Fisch das ist Zander
das ist ein toller Fisch
und das ist dann paniert und hier ist
bei mir ist die Panade auch ein bisschen
anders das Rezept eines ganz berühmten
Kochs und ich versuche das so ein
bisschen zu verfremden und trotzdem
sozusagen den Sinn dahinter zu behalten
soll ich schon sagen wie es gemacht wir
okay wir brauchen dieses Graubrot
schneiden das relativ dünn mhm wird die
Panade und der Trick ist im Grunde
genommen du hast ganz dünnes Graubrot
unten dann den Fisch klar Gewürze
bisschen Senf damit das besser hält und
oben noch mal Brot und was passiert wenn
du es in der Pfanne brätst das Brot
röstet langsam und ist dann wirklich wie
nett getoastet aber eben mit Fett
gemacht also noch ein bisschen
reichhaltiger und der Fisch das Eiweiß
vom Fisch stockt ja bei gut 60° und das
heißt der zieht so durch der ist dann
eben weiß weich weiß und schmeckt
hoffentlich gut und da drauf machen wir
ein Kopfsalat Pesto also nicht mit
rocola wie sonst gemacht W Basilikum
sondern eben mit Kopfsalat das ist so
ein für mich auch ein kindheitsgeschmack
bei uns gab es irgendwie immer Kopfsalat
und das in dem Pesto also mit Olivenöl
mit Pinen kann mit Parmesan pfeffersalz
bisschen kN wie ein Pesto genau und das
schmeckt aber dann hier ist der
Kopfsalat das schmeckt dann wirklich
nach Kopfsalat okay lustig ich habe
beides so in der Variante noch nie
gegessen und nie zubereitet heute das
erste und letzte Mal
vermutlich und ich habe gedacht dann
machen wir vielleicht bisschen
Kartoffelstampf dazu wenn Du möchtest
lecker lecker lecker lecker für mich ist
wichtig dass ich mich kurz damit
beschäftige das ist eher langweilig
bestimmt zum Zugucken weil ich jetzt
auch nicht der
super Crack bin da drin ich guck mal von
welcher Seite ich will es ja relativ ich
schneid mal einen Knust ab ach krass du
bist Linkshänder ich bin ja das sieht
völlig komisch aus wenn man Zug ich bin
Hal Linkshänder das kriegen wir jetzt
auch nicht mehr
geändert das bleibt jetzt so so und
jetzt jetzt muss ich mal gucken wie dünn
ich das weil das ein frisches Brot ist
ja ne wie wie dünn ich das geschnitten
kriege das wird ein kleines Gemetzel ich
Brot
ne ich ma es ich mach es mir ein
bisschen einfacher ja so und
jetztm so ich gucke mal dass ich wir
schneiden das dann muss das Brot ganz
frisch sein oder so ein bisschen Bess
besser wäre wenn es ein bisschen
angetrocknet ist ne das ist jetzt ein
bisschen ungleichmäßig ich muss mal
schauen dass ich ein paar hinkriege die
gleichmäßig und doch dünn sind ja das
ist so die maximale Dicke also es gibt
ja viele Themen mit denen du dich
beschäftigst ne also ich kenne dich ja
als Sportmoderator auch ja da kann ich
jetzt nicht mit Reden schade eigentlich
bei gar nichts tatsächlich echt da kann
ich alleine reden ja da bin ich so da
bin ich so richtig schlecht drin seid
ihr alle nicht Sport interessiert hier
bter den Kameras doch schon und auch
wenn ich mal dann so eine fußballtorte
Football oder was auch immer mache dann
kriege ich immer Infos von meinem Team
weil ich darin einfach sehr schlecht bin
ich wurde auch im Sportunterricht immer
als letzte gewählt ja ich war immer die
die zuletzt auf der Bank saß ja aber
warst du schon immer Sport interessiert
und wurdest deswegen auch Sportmoderator
oder war das so ich wollte ich ja ich
habe früher das hat meine Freunde eher
belästigt wenn wir Fußball gespielt
haben so gegen die Mülltonnen das war
unser Tor dann habe ich immer
mitkommentiert
ah also ich habe nicht einfach nur
gespielt sondern ich habe gesagt da
führt den Ball eng am Fuß geht über die
rechte Seite kommt über l und so weiter
also immer schon mitgesprochen und ich
wollte immer sportm Moderator und
Sportreporter werden und und ich wusste
am Ende meiner Schulzeit wusste ich ganz
sicher was ich werden will und zwar am
Ende meiner Grundschulzeit und ist kein
Spruch okay da war ich 10 ja und da
stand für mich fest damals war es die
Sportschau das war sozusagen die
monstersendung und da war für mich klar
ich werde Sportmoderator und das hat hat
ja einigermaßen geklappt hat super
geklappt es gibt wenige Kinder die in
dem Alter schon sagen was sie wollen und
das dann ja Moment das war natürlich ein
fantastischer Traum also mE die die
Wahrscheinlichkeit Sportmoderator zu
werden ist ja relativ gering selbst wenn
man es will auch sehr erfolgreicher
Sportmoderator dann wenn du es sagst ja
aber ähm das ist ja kommt ja nicht so
häufig vor und ich bin sehr dankbar dass
es geklappt hat und bin heute noch froh
dass ich in Fußballstadion gehen kann
mhm und mir Spiele angucken kann und ja
ich hab eine Saison habe ich mal ja sag
mal Fußball gespielt wo denn selbst
gespielt ja hier in grabenneudorf in
grabneudorf oder beim bei soem ich weiß
nicht mal wieer Verein am Ende FC FC gr
oder so und eine Saison war ich dabei
und wir wurden tatsächlich zweiter wow
wie viele Mannschaften waren drin in der
li wen ich fragen darf drei drei
gut die Gewinnermannschaft war eine
Frauen Handballmannschaft im Fußball ja
und wir waren so die die anderen die
anderen ihr die anderen verloren haben
weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau was die
gemacht haben aber wir wurden zumindest
zweite toll toll ich war in der Abwehr
ja bin aber tatsächlich viel gerannt
okay bis heute nicht warum aber eine
Saison habe ich mitgespielt ja ist gut
ist gut ich habe mir gedacht ich packe
die Kartoffeln jetzt in dampfgara in
Backofen geht schnell brauchen wir kein
Wasser und dann ma ich jetzt auch zum
ersten mal so probieren wir einfach ja
okay ich mach mal hier weiter ja mach du
ruhig
weiter habt ihr ein bisschen Kreppapier
ja
ist das hier hier ist Papier danke geht
es so oder müssen wir die Haut abziehen
nee alles gut das geht so jetzt nehmen
wir ein bisschen Senf also was passiert
ist ich ma einfach Senf drauf das meiste
ma ich a
Brot und zwar eher dünn weil das
natürlich sehr geschmacksintensiv ist
und das hilft mit dass das gut zusammen
babt okay ja sagt man hier babt ja okay
das babt gut ist Babisch B wie gut
SPI Gel gutzel ist Bonbon ich sag immer
ich habe mein Dialekt im Griff aber
eigentlich glaub ich habe ich nicht im
Griff ich verstehe Dich
gut ich glaub manche einer braucht ein
Untertitel aber na das geht schon geht
schon geht schon zu die ganze Zeit das
kann ich gar nicht haben ne ich kann dir
auch was helfen ich kann auch was tun
soll ich schon mal ich weiß nicht s die
P gerne rösten oder kommen die so so so
okay ach du meinst wir können parallel
so Sachen klar ich kann dir ich kann
dich jetzt
unterstützen noch so leckere
Schmandcreme mit burata WoW mit Zitrone
weil es glaube ich auch ganz gut dazu
passt und kochst du daheim dann auch für
dich für euch oder es kommt schon mal
vor aber jetzt natürlich nicht in der
Monster Regelmäßigkeit okay ja ich will
jetzt hier auch nicht vorgeben dass ich
der Monster Koch bin ich mach's halt
ganz gerne mal ja so bin ich aber auch
nicht ich bin ja auch quasi Hobby Köchin
hobbybäckerin hab das mir nur so
nebenher angeeignet ich würde nie
behaupten dass ich das professionell kan
aber ich mach's halt gern ja ja genau so
so ist ein bisschen bei mir auch ja ich
mach's halt gern genau W so eine
Kochsendung noch mal machen werest noch
mal was für dich sag mal so ich fand es
immer interessant tatsächlich das muss
man ja ehrlicherweise mal sagen ich habe
ja nicht gekocht in der Sendung sondern
ich habe daneben gestanden aber da waren
dann Alfons Schubeck und Johann Lafer
und und und und Ralf Zacher und Sacher
Wiener und so diese wirklich großen
Köche ja die dollen Sterne und so weiter
Köche und ich habe halt daneben
gestanden und die Atmosphäre war so dass
wir die ganze Zeit gequatscht haben das
waren immer fünf Köche in der Sendung
und das Sendung dauert eine Stunde einer
machtte eine Vorspeise so ein
Zwischengericht vielleicht ein zweites
Zwischengericht eine Hauptspeise und ein
Dessert also der der oder die am Dessert
hatte am längsten Zeit aber braucht
manchmal auch ein bisschen Vorspeise
totaler Stress Sendung geht los alle
haben gute Laune aber der oder die
musste in 10 Minuten liefern okay und
dann war hier wild was los ja Cornelia
Poletto ich weiß nicht ob duon nam
kennst die war mal be mir in der Sendung
das erste was Sie in meiner Sendung
gesprochen hat war hat mal jemanden
Pflaster oh als allererster absandlung
hat sie sich mal schön in Finger
geschnitten okay und wer durfte dann
immer probieren ja erst die Köche
untereinander und die haben dann ganz
ehrlich miteinander gesprochen wirklich
also wenn Johan Laer gesagt hat hat das
du genommen das Gericht und hat dann
gesagt so und hat gesagt also zu
hstlichter oder so also der Teller auf
dem das angerichtet ist das ist wirklich
ein schönes Stück und hat wieder
weggestellt dann wusste man okay alles
klar das war das war eine
Katastrophe okay oder interessant wenn
sag interessant wenn im Zeugnis steht
hat sich bemüht ja ja ja genau ich kann
hier gleich mal die so SEAG schildern
was ich gemacht habe und auch die
Probleme die entstehen und mir dann auch
gleich passiert sind also das ist im
Grunde genommen ein Fischstäbchen ja das
ist jetzt obenbrot untenbrot bisschen
Senf das Brot war sehr frisch das ist
dann z.B beim Schneiden zerfällt das so
das ist dann natürlich ein bisschen blöd
beim Wenden wenn du genug Senf dabei
hast dann könnte es sein dass es hält
aber wir schauen mal und woher kommt das
Gericht also woher hast du das das hat
einer der Köche bei mir in der Sendung
mal
gemacht so ähnlich und der kam halt auch
mit der Ansage und sagte Fischstäbchen
und dann haben wir gesagt wie
Fischstäbchen uns veräppeln und dann
waren das diese Fischstäbchen und die
sind wirklich extrem schmackhaftig bin
mal gespannt okay ich sehe was du meinst
mit dem Brot mit dem Brot ja aber das
ist aber das das kppt kein Drama das
verspielt sich so ich guck mal ich hier
noch eine Scheibe ordentlich hinkriege
zu wüst macht da siehst du da ist jetzt
auch wieder abgebröselt na komm macht
nichts okay so und durch diese mattee
geht die Induktion ja okay die schützt
praktisch nur den Herd ah ich dachte
dass du das nur so zum abstellen aber
auch zum Kochen genau genau ja die das
schmilzt nicht und gar nicht das
schmilzt nicht so ein platinsilikon und
dann okay viel oder ein bisschen
bisschen noch also muss nicht schwimmen
aber so ja reicht danke gut ja ach so
jetzt mal die ganze Wahrheit ist
natürlich wollt mir nicht noch was dazu
K nicht das Pesto schnellmer weil das
geht flott oder lassen wir das mal kurz
aus noch okay fät mir gerade ein was
magst Du noch Pinienkerne Olivenöl
Pfeffer salzbra Parmesan liegt aber auch
schon ja ich kann den schon mal reiben
wenn du magst ja darf ich mir diesen
stmixer mal nehmen darfst alles nehmen
ja machst jetzt auch alles ohne
Mengenangabe ne einfach so frei Schnauz
a ach so ja ja oh Gott schlimm ne nee
das ist gut beim Kochen beim Kochen kann
man das ja machen ist ja das Schöne am
Kochen beim Backen mus bisschen
schwierig beim backen muss man immer so
nachmaß gut dann brauche ich
Olivenöl mhm m
ordentlich ne
ordentlich nicht an der falschen Stelle
sparen das lie reicht erstmal danke mal
gucken was passiert also
beide im ersten Moment dauert's und dann
denkt man das kann gar nicht sein dass
das
funktioniert von der Menge eigentlich
schon ausreichend ja so jetzt machen wir
ein bisschen Parmesan rein und ein paar
mehr pinenkerne da ist ja auch das ist
ja
Fett sal
ja okay und jetzt ist das ja noch
relativ flüssig sage ich mal und das
kannst Du weniger flüssig kriegen indem
du mehr koffsalat nimmst ich nehme am
liebsten natürlich diese jungen gelben
Blätter da aus der Mitte Knofi
rein und man macht meistens von diesem
Kopfsalat Pesto viel zu viel wie wir
jetzt auch das ist ja nur so ein kleiner
KL auf die fischstel aber kann man ja
gut aufheben ja und du kannst es auch zu
Nudeln essen das ist ein Pesto
idealerweise sollte es nach Kopfsalat
schmecken ob Pfeffers Salz reichen das
gucken wir gleich
mhm ein bisschen Salz aber es schmeckt
krass nach Salat Kopfsalat ne mhm ist
doch lustiger Geschmack oder mhm und es
ist und es ist ganz klar ein Pesto kann
üb auch noch Parmesan Reen ganz klar
Pesto aber es ist eben der
Grundgeschmack ein Ticken anderer durch
den Kopfsalat ich lass mal weil ich
gerne viel Salze bist du hier so akkurat
dass für die Löffel die wir schon mal
benutz hab wegtun ja okay dann deswegen
habe ich gleich ein paar mehr okay dann
bleibt es dabei das so die Lehrerin in
mir weil ich natürlich wenn du eine
Schulklasse hast mit 30 Kindern dann
willst du das nicht essen wenn da jeder
mit seinem Löffel schon mal drin war ja
oder halt alle krank am nächsten Tag
genau deswegen gab's immer probierlöffel
und Löffel das ist verrückt wie der
Kopfs man denkt das ja nicht ne dass der
kannst ruhig rein maachen ne ich wollte
gerade sagen die Partnerin in mir die
ist sparsam ja BST du so sparsam ja
schon ich kratze immer alles aus machst
du auch am vierten Advent zwei Kerzen an
und stellst D vor Spiegel ja oh das ma
ich dieses Jahr nee aber ich kratze
tatsächlich alles aus mit einem
Teigschaber immer machen wir mal
so boah lecker
mhm ist gut ne oder kann man lassen ist
aber salzig jetzt chuldigung aber gut
fin's richtig gut probiert mal ich
schmecke kaum noch Knoblauch raus in
vielen Gerichten weil ich so oft
Knoblauch benutze wirklich WE ist
richtig lecker gar nicht so schlecht
oder und was sagt ihr sehr gut ja okay
dann jimmer beeindruckt wenn Männer
kochen können ne eine Sache schon mal
gelogen wollen wir nicht einfach
abbrechen woll einfach abbrechen können
wir einfach die
Torte ne ne die kan jetzt einfach
ignorieren das einmal ganz kurz ins Eis
ich WE das eigentlich nicht aber einfach
für 10 Minuten bisschen dann wird fester
ja okay vergessen einfach die Torte die
kann nicht so gut sein wie bei seiner
Mama bin bisschen also ich hatte beim
Backen hatte ich schon so bisschen hast
du Puls gehabt so wie süß ja ja vor
allem stand der da im Rezept ein
fertiger Biskuit und dann war ich so oh
Gott wie sieht denn ein fertiger Biskuit
aus wie hoch ist der und dann war meiner
hoch und dann dachte ich das ist doch zu
hoch das kann ich doch jetzt nicht
machen der muss doch jetzt geschnitten
werden
und dann habe ich einfach so nach meinem
Gefühl gedacht so mache ich jetzt ich
vertraue auf dein Gefühl ich habe ein
gutes Gefühl für dein Gefühl wo geht
sowas an hier hier ah hier so und jetzt
gehe ich mal hier aus sieben ja okay
wollen wir noch ein bisschen Gemüse dazu
machen oder wir Kartoffelstampf lassen
wie du magst man soll das Glück ja nicht
zwingen ne dann lassen wir es doch oder
aber sieht gut aus finde ich sieht auch
sehr gesund aus das ist die ganze Zeit
mit im Bild wir denken uns das einfach
machst du da Salz rein ja aber das ist
das ist
mein okay herzhaft ich dachte gerade
jetzt in mein Kuchen kein Salz ne ne ne
das machen wir nicht also außer einer
Prise genau wie lange braucht dein
Kartoffelstampf noch eigentlich ist es
auch durch Ken
[Musik]
wir ich nehme mal hier ein Stäbchen zum
gucken aber die
müssten gut sein bin natürlich der
totale Schisser jetzt ob das
funktioniert ich probi mal ja Minute tu
viele rein in ein funktioniert ja das
wird schon S kartoffelstauf mit
Buttermilch oder bisschen Spanisch mit
Olivenöl
Zitrone habe ich nicht probiert also
interessant aber interessiert mich
wirklich also mach S aieren mit Butter
und Milch kenne ich genau hatte ich eine
Zeit lang als Hauptnahrungsmittel und
ich habe hier nämlich einen Koch bei uns
im Team und den habe ich gefragt was
gibt den noch für Kartoffelstampf
Alternativen und er meinte zum Fisch
würde passen Olivenöl Zitrone habe ich
gedacht gut das probieren wir jetzt mal
ich würde es einfach mal sagen viel
Olivenöl vi bisschen
Knoblauch ja man kann das eigentlich
ganz gut verfolgen hier so ein der Seite
man sieht dann ja wie das eiiweiß
anfängt zu stocken ne das braucht aber
jetzt so ich sag mal von jetzt 5 6
Minuten wenn du es aber zu heiß machst
dann ist es Brot schwarz in der
Zwischenzeit das eine gute mittlere
Temperatur finden ja ja so auch so ein
bisschen hin und her ich finde sowieso
das werden manchmal in Rezepten steht
dann drin ja auf was weiß ich auf sieben
oder auf mitittler Stufe ja es ist doch
viel angenehmer dass man ein bisschen
mit der Temperatur spielt also D man nim
sie halt runter wenn man Spiegelei macht
und das auf
voller Stärke dann ist ja klar dass es
an den Seiten anbrennt aber wenn es
eigentlich so ist wie Du willst ist nur
noch ein bisschen glibbrig und dann
machst halt runter und lass es ein paar
Minuten stehen das zieht alles durch
aber das Ding ist du hast halt ein gutes
Gefühl für Essen und viele haben das
einfach nicht deswegen habe ich auch in
meinen Rezepten immer so die richtig
perfekte Angabe gerade beim backen weil
viele einfach nicht nach nach Gefühl
auch abschmecken können beispielsweise
wenn du da sagst mit Salz und Pfeffer
abschmecken würzen viele oft tatsächlich
zu wenig mhm und haben nicht so das
Gefühl für Konsistenz
und ja deswegen ich find's gut wenn man
das intuitiv kann aber manche müssen das
noch lernen okay ich habe jetzt hier
einfach mal Knoblauch ins
Olivenöl mach bisschen Zitronenschale
ran und dann probiere ich das jetzt mal
mit der
Kartoffel ist ja doch warm ne meine
Mutter sagt immer kaltkuchen ist noch
nicht erfunden ich bin auch heute so
bisschen experimentierfreudig sehe ich
gerade normal ist alles so in meinen
Videos schon fertiger strukturiert aber
heute habe ich mir gedacht so also es
sieht jetzt eigentlich so aus als könnte
es ganz gut klappen so ja das sieht gut
aus ja sag das ist jetzt nicht kann man
natürlich akkurater schneiden alles und
dann sieht das wirklich wie
Fischstäbchen aber man darf ja noch ein
Unterschied zu ja Tiefkühlware sehen
fühl mal also wenn du drauf gehst dann
fühlst du dass das schon leicht geröstet
ist und du siehst eben auch dass es
anfängt durchzuziehen genau das braucht
jetzt einfach Moment Ruhe und ja ja
danke danke so die Kartoffeln sind jetzt
glaube ich auch
gut okay wir testen es jetzt mal
aber ich glaube gerade Fisch ist ja
finde ich ist so eine Königsdisziplin
weil den auf dem
punktgarn und dann noch für viele
Menschen hier die kleine Menge also die
kleinen stüchen das macht ein bisschen
gefälliger wenn du z.B eine seezone
machst was ja kein Hexenwerk ist oder
eine Scholle dann brauchst du einfach
eine große PME
wenn drinck das kann werden ich habe
immer die große eckige die ist auch
super komm über gleichmäßig die Hitze
hin ja vor allem für eckige Pfannkuchen
auch das kurz aus so für Spargel wir
sind hier spargelregion ja und dann kann
man schön eckige Pfannkuchen backen und
dann den Spargel perfekt einrollen
überall gleich
viel das geht bei mir
noch h wier runtermchen mhm weil man
sieht dann gleich wenn das Brot zu
dunkel ist dann ist der Spaß vorbei ja
okay ich weiß jetzt nicht ob unser
kartoffelstamp was ist aber ja probier
doch probier wir mal nur vom Gefühl kte
man hast du Muskat drin
ja nur
V noch
Salz
mh aber lecker ja ich glaube es wird
ganz frisch so würde F bisschen ja
machen wir noch mehr dar ich einfach ja
bitte mach einfach s stop du mach du
ruhig ich bin für Olivenöl bin ich sehr
damit einer muss ja schuld sein und ich
würde noch sum rein
machen ein Essigbaum Gewürz dezent ja
weil das eine schöne Säure hat od W du
magst
gerne nieder
täentlen ich guck mal ob ich Rosmarin
hab ne das war nur Idee das ist du musst
da ja nicht hör um Gottes will nicht auf
mich sieht gut
aus das ist jetzt Zander der Fisch und
das ist relativ dankbar ja weil der
festes Fleisch hat aber hellweiß also
und vom Geschmack her wenn jetzt jemand
Fisch nicht so bomb lecker findet das
haut ich jetzt nicht um also du bist
nicht gleich isst du gern Fisch und viel
ich ich esse gern Fisch um weit zu sagen
meistens in Restaurants wo ich Fisch
sehr gut ist okay und frisch aber da
habt ihr auch in Hamburg so eine größere
vi noch weiter nördlich und so da gibt's
schon da gibt's schon echt gute also
wenn jemand das was eine Seezunge wenn
einer jeden Tag Seezunge macht 20 30
Stück das ist natürlich was anderes als
wenn du das erstmal mit zu tun l ich
muss einfach nur noch mal kontrollieren
weil ich will dass es so ja weil ich
weiß gar nicht ob es hier an mir liegt
ich weiß nicht Jessie müsst ihr sagen
aber hier haben wir nicht so viel Fisch
gell weil bei uns klar der Fisch halt
nicht hier aus der Region kommt und ja
und wenn kommt da halt mit den
entsprechenden Lieferanten und
bestimmt auch gute Ware genau aber halt
nicht so wie frisch von frisch gefischt
woll wir ich hier anrichten wir können
hier anrichten und dann nehmen wir mit
dann hol ich mal Teller ich hab die
Teller hier guck mal magst du schwarz
grau ich glaube die sind freundlich ne
genau freundlich
hier so noch ein bisschen angemacht um
es noch mal so ein bisschen anzuziehen
aber es ist wir müssen ja auch keine
monsterptionen aufgeben genau dann
darfst du gerne
anrichten ich bin
aufgeregt ich habe hier Servierbesteck
wenn du was brauchst ich am liebsten so
soll ich da jetzt hier so richtig so so
kleine Kunstwerke raus machen also K so
wie Du willst na ja ich finde das sieht
gekonnt aus hätten man natürlich warm
machen können die Teller oh ja kleine
Kritik hier bnote so nächstes Mal ich
habe ein
Heißluftfön und ein Bunsenbrenner den
darfst du gerne benutzen und zwar für
die Haare ja ist ist okay wenn ich da so
so Nocker draus ma praktisch klar ja das
war nichts das sieht gut aus mir fehlt
halt die Übung ne ich müss das alles
viel häufiger machen wie wär es denn mit
einem kochchannel wo du so täglich ja
doch doch doch ja ich bin kurz davor
pass auf ich bin kurz davor ja wo du so
täglich deine Essgewohnheiten ja aber
mich würde dann reizen so also nichts
wegschmeißen Sachen aufbrauchen und mich
immer inspirieren lassen von dem was
irgendwie noch da ist mhm immer so
restewertung auch ja fin ich gut ich
kann dir anbieten du kannst jederzeit
hier unsere Kulisse benutzen wir haben
viele Küchen und viel Technik sei
vorsichtig mit solchen
anboten noch ein Zimmer frei dann komme
ich nämich morgen mit Gepäck haben wir
auch dann kannst du hier deine
Kochsendung machen
so habt ihr alle gehört haben wir auf
Kamera ja okay die Community kann ja
einfach schon mal einen Namen für die
Kochsendung finden dann steht das
unmittelbar bevor das genau in die
Kommentare einfach schreiben ja wie dann
ma ich das jetzt ne ach komm eigentlich
W es besser das nur mit einem aber wir
haben jetzt jetzt sind zwei und einmal
eins jetzt Braue ich kurz kpapier mhm ja
das ist über eine schöne Idee also die
Sendung im ZDF hieß Kerners Köche nicht
etwa kerner kocht in meinem Wikipedia
einracht steht dass die kerner kocht
hieß das stimmt nicht das wäre auch eine
glatte Lüge gewesen we stand echt nur
daneben okay das aber
gerne Kner kocht vor Wut hätte man
manchmal aber sonst eher nicht so jetzt
haben wir das genug gequatscht hier und
das müsste jetzt eigentlich noch ein
Ticken fester sein und das würde ich
einfach so fast ein bisschen zu viel
aber schön könte natürlich B Pfeffer
hier so paprik Gemüse könnte man mhm
eigentlich ein Paprika pfenchelgemüse
finde ich ideal dazu nur in in der
Pfanne extra kurz anziehen ja sie ist es
jetzt langweilig zu wenig ist das
funieren genau perfekt das sagst du
jetzt doch genau perfekt okay dann stell
das noch mal kalt
probieren wir mal okay gehen wir mal zum
Tisch und
probieren was hast du denn was ist denn
das
ach das ma ich mal aus hier sonst wir
aus ist hier
gut so sind wir mal gespannt hab ein
bisschen Angst ach quatsch das sieht
super
aus das riecht gut ja gucken wir mal
also vielen Dank schon mal fürs Kochen
danke für die Einladung lass uns all die
Freundlichkeiten vorher austauschen
gegessen hast dann wird der Ton schärfer
davor habe ich keine Angst ich habe eher
vor der Torte Angst ja okay alles klar
aber Angst hilft ja nicht in der Küche
einfach machen ich probi mal gerade das
kartoffelzeug
toll toll wie hieß das Gewürz was du
noch drinest sum essigbaumgeürz okay
jetzt Stunde der Wahrheit hier sieht
richtig gut aus und ich find sehr
angenehm dass es hier drin nicht
nachfisch rie ja und und man sieht also
wer kein Fisch mag die gute Nachricht
man sieht den Fisch ja kaum ja man
riecht i nicht man sieht i nicht
aber mhm fischchäbchen mhm ab du bist
der Vorbild du darfst nicht mit voll
Mund essen reden okay ich schon ich bin
hier zu Gast kann mich ja benehmen wie
die Axt im
Walde jetzt komm ich find's mega lecker
und das Pesto auf die Idee muss man
erstmal kommen fin auch gar nicht so
schlecht ich find's richtig gut mein
Team darf auch gleich probieren die
freut sich schon darf man gar nicht
sagen ne dass man das ist das ist nicht
ursprünglich meine Idee aber wir haben
es heute gekocht man sagt dirmer
Selbstlob stinkt aber bei uns schmeckt
ja ne super ach Eigenlob ja da gibt's
von Sido eine schöne
Textzeile die heißt Eigenlob
stimmt finde ich ganz niedlich hier
stimmt's
auch was was wollen wir so lassen weil
es einfach so schön aussieht das K wir
wir können jetzt gleich noch essen
natürlich aber die Frage ist willst du
erst aufwessen und dann wagen wir die
Torte ja ne oder soll ich schon mal
holen und du probierst einfach mal und
ich schau alles voller Tisch aber ich
möchte das einmal ja was nim einfach was
das mache ich wie burata ziehen wir ein
bisschen auseinander ja so genau m wow
okay ich nehme nur so ein kleines Stück
und was sag noch mal was in dem
schmantcremezeug dain ist bisschen ja
bisschen
zitronenabrib Zitronensaft
SalzPfeffer und Paprika mhm undmnt okay
probiere ich jetzt ziemlich einfach und
ist auch so so ein brottunk Rezept was
also das ist jetzt falsch dass ich hier
auf ein Teller mache doch doch geht auch
ich auch pur ja ich esse es auch dann
gern
pur so zpeise
mm ist mir vorhin so spontan noch
eingefallen weil ich dachte Zitrone
Kartoffel ist und das kannst du dir also
diese Basis die ist ja jetzt schon sehr
würzig und sehr frisch die kannst du ja
jetzt sousagen pimpen für wen auch immer
der kommt wenn einer kommt der totalen
Bock auf scharf hat der kriegt scharf
genau istst du gern scharf ich kann
scharf essen ja okay ja ich esse gern
scharf ja also außer wenn es jetzt wenn
dir wenn der alles wegzimmert aus dem
Mund so das natürlich nicht ne
aber dann wahrscheinlich nicht meine
Schärfe ja also beim Asiaten wenn ich
dann sage scharf mhm dann gucken die so
D ne ne nicht so scharf so europäische
Schärfe na ja mhm ich probiere das mal
gerade mit Kartoffeln boah ich finde
also ich bin jetzt richtig Fan davon ich
werde das Nachkochen für meine Kinder
weißt du was auch nicht schlecht ist
diese schmandgeschichte mit dem
kartoffelsch zusammen und schön ist in
deinem Kanal kann man ja so lange essen
wie man will und
quatschen ich hätte jetzt schon dreimal
sagen müssen dass ich die nachfolgenden
Sendung entsprechend verzögern und alle
schauen dabei zu heute schon heute schon
heute um 10:3 uh das schöne wir können
so lange wir wollen W sagen wir essen
kurz auf und dann schauen wir gleich mal
ob meine Torte dir schmeckt ich habe ein
gutes Gefühl probier noch mal das mit
dem
kartoffelsch das finde
ich
mhm mhm mhm mhm
ja gut der Mon wir muss es noch ganz
kurz glatt streichen das ist ja dein
signiter move ne das ist ja das ist das
mussm ja hm ganz toll sieht bisschen aus
wie so eine tiramisou Torte
ja tiramisou kann wie jeder ja das ist
hier dein lieblingsk deine
Lieblingstorte oh ist meine Geburts also
ist mein Geburtstagskuchen der hast du
jedes Jahr zum Geburtstag als Kind aber
der war natürlich nie so perfekt sondern
das war so ein fertig fertiger Boden
Biskuitboden den man im Supermarkt kauft
und dann einfach diese Creme drauf und
ja ich ich hoffe es schmeckt dir und
Kakao drüber okay ja Kakao drüber genau
Nacht im Kühlschrank das ist wichtig KST
hier schon perfekt aus ja achso ich weiß
schon wo die Gabeln sind ja stimmt
willst hier Test oder so Tisch ich kann
kaum warten al ist mir komm wir gehen
zum Tisch komm oh
Gott ich glaube es kann nicht jeder
behaupten die
lieblingsgeburtstagstorte von Johannes
bener gebacken zu haben ja vielen vielen
Dank das
ist das sieht sehr gut aus und ich
möchte jetzt auch eigentlich essen ja du
dar zack ich kann auch gerne mal meinen
Puls checken mein Herz klopft nämlich
richtig
mhm ein wirklich ein Geschmack meiner
Kindheit ja es ähm schmeckt es dir oder
findest du es langweilig M M weißt du
was ich richtig mag ich finde es
schmeckt so richtig lecker frisch nach
Quark ja m eigentlich je mehr man ist
desto gesünder ist es ja Proteinshake
mhm und wenn ich das hier dein Boden ist
natürlich ganz toll ist richtig danke
ich w auch nicht kann man nicht kaufen
ja ich WUs nicht so vom Verhältnis ab
ich glaub es passt super darf ich das
Rezept so dann veröffentlichen ja ja ja
genau Credits zu meiner Mama ja okay die
die das ist ihr Kuchen sozusagen und ich
mache mit dir eine kleine Wette du
kannst sagen warum will ist mir völlig
egal ich verspreche dir diese Tote wird
null Uhr nicht erleben auf jeden Fall
vorher aufgegessen die schmeckt Hal auch
echt gut lecker locker leicht mega danke
fürs Rezept und ganz lieben Dank dass du
hier bist to eine Freude ja muss ich
schon gehen du darfst no bleiben auch
Gästezimmer genug Platz genug Küchen ich
war auch heute ziemlich aufgeregt weil
es se jetzt so meine erste Sendung ist
oder die erste Folge für die Sendung in
der ich sage okay Küche frei hier darf
jetzt jeder Gast kommen und einfach
meine Küche übernehmen und Kochen und
Backen was er oder sie möchte und wenn
man dann immer so belohnt wird kann ich
dir sagen dass sehr viele Menschen hier
die Küche übernehmen werden ja hoffen
wir
mal
mhm ja würde ich sagen alle Rezepte
findet ihr wie immer in der App ganz
lieben Dank dass du hier bist wir
genießen jetzt noch unser Essen und die
Torte und ich bin gespannt in wie viel
Minuten sie verputzt ist und ich möchte
euch danken für die Aufmerksamkeit aber
noch mehr dir für die Einladung das hat
großen Spaß gemacht ja danke dass du da
bist ich bin also eigentlich immer noch
ja gerne ich bin immer noch überwältigt
dass du da bist weil es ein einfach so
normal ist ne ja ich freue mich auch
aber so ein bisschen abnormal schon ne
also ich meine wer hat schon Johannes
bener in seiner Küche sitzen s mal
ehrlich danke fürs einschalten und ich
würde sagen ihr kommt jetzt auch alle
Teller gabelbesteck holt euch Essen und
genießt mal das Essen es ist richtig
lecker und lasass mich die Bette
gewinnen
mhm ja die wenn du ein gekauften
Tortenboden nimmst der hat ja so leich
der hü an der Seite mhm also so dieser
obstkuchenboden
kommt doch
her sag ehrlich was hast
[Musik]
du diese fischgeschichte hol Rig stüle
und es ist
fischächen still am Tisch kein
schlechtes
Zeichen immer
[Musik]
gut